Once upon a time, a tiger was trapped in a cage.
The tiger tried to squeeze out.
But the bars were too close together.
The tiger tried to bite through the bars.
But the bars were too hard.
The tiger shook the bars.
And he bit them.
But it was no use.
He could not get out.
A man came strolling by the cage.
"Please, let me out!" cried the tiger.
"Oh, I cannot help you," said the man.
"If I let you out, you would eat me."
"Oh no, I would never eat you," promised the tiger.
"Please free me and I will be your servant for the rest of your days."
And the tiger cried and begged and the man listened.
And then after a while, he felt sorry for the tiger.
The man opened the door to the cage and the tiger leapt out.
He did not say thank you.
Instead he said, "You look delicious."